le gîte et du couvert seront maintenant
offerts aux chats de chanteloup les
vignes à quelques pas du chapiteau de la
compagnie des contraire un petit
bâtiment aux allures de cabanes de
jardin trône depuis quelques semaines à
l'intérieur un foyer pour chats errants
ils sont nourris à l'extérieur déjà dans
un premier temps l'on voit ici avec un
système de récupération d'eau de pluie
ils ont également une première petite
cabane où ils peuvent s'abriter et puis
ensuite ils peuvent utiliser ce lieu
avec l'intermédiaire de deux trappes qui
sont posées sur le latéralement sur le
chat tipi ça les abritent pendant
l'hiver quand il fait froid quand il ya
de la pluie ou quand il ya trop de vent
c'est beaucoup plus agréable pour eux
comme pour n'importe quel animal d'être
à l'abri dans les intempéries ils ont
vraiment besoin parce que deux fois on
trouve des chats vraiment mal en point
qui a besoin de l'aide une fois qu'ils
sont rentrés à l'intérieur vous avez ici
à nouveau de la nourriture protéger donc
on a de chaque côté et puis ils ont ici
tout tout un tas de coussins de lieux où
ils peuvent être vraiment à l'abri et au
chaud un équipement offert par one voice
une association nationale qui luttent
contre l'errance féline et la
municipalité de chanteloup les vignes il
vient compléter les actions de
l'association chante l'ouvèze sos matou
créé il ya un an une dizaine de
personnes agissent au quotidien on est
là pour sauver les chats errants déjà
tout ce qui échappe que ce soit avant ou
même un chat abandonné les stériliser
les identifier à roulettes sur le
terrain ce qui a aidé à faire adopter le
reste c'est sociable ensuite il ya le
nourrissage un chat en bonne santé bien
nourris sera en bonne santé donc il va
développer moins de maladies donc ça
c'est laid c'est le maillon dur si vous
voulez qu'il faut vraiment mais tant
qu'à et là vraiment c'est le plus donc
on est ravi un peu de réconfort à défaut
d'une famille pour ses chats abandonnés
notamment après le confinement ou ses
chatons né dans la nature chanteloup les
vignes est la première ville des
yvelines a bénéficié de ce dispositif